[Musique]
si l'heure est censé être à la fête à
monaco pour célébrer le jour souverain
fête nationale du pays la rencontre
traditionnelle entre une famille
princière et ses sujets un véritable
baromètre de popularité
charlene de monaco ne pourra pourtant
pas y participer en raison de son état
de santé c'est le prince albert lui même
qui révèle que sa femme est fébrile
suite à des complications d'une
infection orl elle va mieux mais elle a
encore besoin de repose tranquillité il
ya une fatigue et pas seulement
physiques qui ne peut se traiter que par
une période de repos et par un suivi si
albert ii de monaco se veut rassurant
certaines rumeurs indiquent que la
princesse serait en fait interner dans
un centre de désintoxication pour faire
face à une supposée addiction aux
antidouleurs et aux somnifères
alors êtes vous inquiet pour la santé de
charlene de monaco quoi qu'il en soit
les monégasques espèrent que leur
princesse sera bientôt remise sur pied
ce soir le journaliste bertrand des
coeurs c'est myriam palombes à
directrice déléguée chiffres qui
viennent nous donner de ses nouvelles
après bien sûr jean luc non plus
pour l'instant c'est bien berton decker
merci bertrand della vous êtes merci
bertrand d'état des spécialistes de la
monarchie le paraguay ça va bertrand
bertrand est ce que vous savez de quoi
souffre
charlène c'est important j'aime beaucoup
le prince albert qui est très sympa
c'est un sportif et tous et je suis
inquiet pour charlene on est tous on est
juste très accrocheur c'est toujours un
peu on aura sera de dons
sans faire à l'aide au peuple
aujourd'hui donc 19 novembre est le jour
le plus important pour monaco pourquoi
puisque c'est le jour de la fête
nationale ils ont regardé ou une fois
depuis 1949 jour de l'aca régnait le 19
novembre est vraiment le point culminant
en principauté de monaco on a tous cru
après six mois d'absence que charlène
reflet en principauté le 8 novembre pour
pouvoir assister à cet événement et puis
là apparemment non puisque le magazine
public nous révèle donc ce matin qu'en
réalité la princesse serait interné à
l'hôpital princesse grace de monaco
interne est rousse à à l'hôpital
princesse grace de monaco de monaco
c'est ce que révèle bloqué ce cas là
elle serait dans le département de
psychiatrie aie aie où il y aurait donc
un grave problème
psychologique
genre tu qu'elle de clara sera on est
obligé de parler au conditionnel parce
que personne n'est vraiment un monaco
c'est très particulier l'excellent ne
l'avouera halal à doha la gauche
elle a quoi bertrand la pauvre
jose a été tranquille sauf
[Musique]
problème concernant concernant charlene
puisqu'il ya déjà longtemps que l'on que
l'on craint pour l'état de santé de
charlène puisque si on fait un bref
récapitulatif parce qu'elle a eue chine
l'iaaf déjà aux noms plus ou moins que
ça ne va plus elle a commencé déjà à
multiplier les opérations de chirurgie
esthétique c'est ça on a quand même pu
le voir ce qu'est ce qu'elle a reçu
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
elle a fait quand même refaire pas mal
de shoah figure voit pas le visage et
dernièrement ses dents notamment
l'entièreté de la wii mais surtout
surtout ce qui nous a surtout alerter
qui traduit un mal-être en fait en mal
être appuyé à la finesse
et
donc il ya quelques mois elle est
apparue avec la une coupe de cheveux
absolument nouvelle est pour le moins
étonnante là dans le milieu du gotha
elle est apparue les cheveux rasés non
non ça c'est ça sur la place et son
retour il y avait que j'avais les
cheveux 9 absolument pas tant qu'ennemi
avec un oui apple à britney de la mine
la presse l'avait rebaptisé pourquoi
parce qu'apparemment elle aurait saisi
une belle de ciseaux pour pouvoir se
couper les cheveux ce qui traduit
vraiment à nouveau un mal être
psychologique et donc il ya depuis
longtemps on soupçonne on soupçonne ce
mal être une petite fabrique de
l'apparemment il est officiel d'après le
communiqué donc café le prince où il dit
que la princesse souffrent dans un état
de fatigue il niait les faits
c'est vrai je vis et y at-il ou
princesse diana total charlene de monaco
dont il sera absente lors de la fête
nationale ça veut dire que son état
initial
ç'a aidé par
ses décors
il est difficile d'avoir des
informations vraiment une horloge boulle
à la dgre après le bac s qui avait mis
les graves il est très présente a
décliné
[Rires]
[Musique]
encore s'éloigner de la principauté
campagne non puisque je viens de vous
dire qu'elle était à l'hôpital princesse
grâce
la journée est donc france moment elle
est à l'hôpital de grasse qu'est ce qui
se passe entre albert et charlene
ces relais tous là non c'est fini de
cinq ans non non c'est très difficile à
dire ils sont encore ensemble mariage
était célébré il ya dix ans en tout cas
ce que l'on peut dire vraiment c'est que
charlène un probablement énormément de
mal à s'adapter à son rôle de princesse
hérite son rôle de princesse elle épouse
le prince souverain et à me lasser très
très important si vous me permettez une
petite parentalité tous que oui là
l'intégralité des monarchies sont
quasiment des monarchies
constitutionnelles
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
souverains ont essentiellement un rôle
de représentation c'est sympa à monaco à
monaco albert est vraiment le chef
d'antenne c'est à dire que le pouvoir
exécutif législatif et judiciaire est
rendu en voient s'allumer rond bon voilà
il est vraiment à la tête de la firme
monaco un chef d ça c'est en chef c'est
vrai chef d'état dans le coup ce qui
veut donc dire que le rôle de son épouse
est hyper important elle est la première
dame de la principauté donc s'il ira ce
titre la shazam
fatigue et peut-être elle est peut-être
fatigué je paie 500 pi2 de dessins sur
les lois de son pays d'origine à
l'australie du sud
la continuité
adacore litas parce que c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que cela charlene a eu
énormément de mal à s'adapter elle a
nagé un an avant oui oui elle était
championne allowed to say we un
championnat c'est une médaille d'or oui
oui vous savez les deux cas l'aja n'est
pas championne olympique mais très doué
mais il s'est dit championne olympique
c'est que l'équipe championne olympique
crois qu'ils se trompent ah oui vous
avez là une médaille d'or elle est
humaine en donnant de dollars à tunis
moi je pense wallace est grande elle a
des épaules de m oui oui et peut-être
donc elle été si dur aussi essentielle
sans rigoler c'est une tannée mais ce
n'est pas difficile moi c'est tranquille
c'est impossible d'être noir c est noir
c'est très très difficile pourquoi parce
que pour charlène dites-vous en
permanence qu'il ya quand même l'ombre
écrasante de grave crise a de ce fait
sur ses épaules et qui est toujours
présente en principauté tout le monde
vénère grâce à la sorte mais de la part
de charlène il y as je pense aussi on
pourrait peut-être le dire j'ose le dire
peut être un manque dans fear de la part
de charlene était excessivement me ce
sens qu'elle a pardonné une travail on
nous donne envie mais voilà c'est à dire
que grâce souffrait par exemple je vous
donne un détail parmi mille autres grâce
souffrait de myopie extrême elle ne
voyage il a donc enfin stable
elle était obligée de porter de grosses
lunettes de grosses lunettes en
permanence et elle elle ne supportait
pas porter ses lunettes lors des
réceptions officielles ont qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait grâce la table à
l'époque des grands appartements pouvait
accueillir 36 personnes grâce étudié par
car le plan de ta nom et elle s'avère
utile dans sa ferme les caps lui et elle
savait pertinemment que si un pilote est
de 45 de créer alors elle avait en face
d'elle l'arche n'avait pas de facs avait
vraiment face à bages et josh minutes
voilà c'est le pilote est de 45 degrés
de l'autre côté elle avait en face
d'elle par exemple sur mineurs
l'archevêque mais chez pas des gens quoi
le savait elle en fait des muscats
travail vocal moyens dans quel but elle
connaissait toute la table mais j'aurai
atteint bout de la table ça fait pareil
on m'avait rythme mais ça arrive à un
vrai que ça ce que je tente de vous
expliquer c'est que non seulement elle
savait l2 elle savait qu'ils étaient
enfin tel mais savait comment l'appeler
aussi on n'appelle pas l'archevêque de
monaco comme on appelle l'or ça d'après
souffrent il ya tout un protocole va
être important l'archevêque c'est
monseigneur à monseigneur l'ambassadeur
vous lui donnerez le titre des lourds
et donc où la mer est très difficile à
prendre
ils sont très dissipée sont très
dissipée et moi aussi c'est vous dire si
vous me permettez de la signature ici
personne je pense n'a jamais été jusqu'à
travailler autant associés il est
regrettable de constater aujourd'hui je
ne jette pas du tout d'un pierre
blanchard hélène parce qu'on ne tire pas
sur une ambulance mais il est quand même
regrettable
aujourd'hui de constater que après onze
ans de mariage pratiquement mon sens
elle ne parraine toujours pas le
français non elle ne balbutie mais elle
ne le parle pas russe et le français est
la langue nationale à monaco et cela est
loin d'être anecdotique de quoi parce
que ça la rend fermait bien sûr ya six
ans d'ouvrir absolument et elle a contre
elle quasiment l'intégralité de la
population monégasque
la télé réalité des monégasques qui sont
quarante mille à monaco quand même il y
a deux entités essentiellement il ya les
purs monégasque a reçu de souche qui
reproche à charlène de ne pas parler le
français alors je vous parle même pas du
monégasque qui est un dialogue qui se
rapprochent lors du provençal et il y à
l'autre population de monaco qui est
peuplé de millionnaire non personne sur
trois à monaco est millionnaire qui
vivent dans des appartements de luxe
avec piscine monaco le mètre carré c'est
quoi ces quatre-vingt mille
basé ses 90 90 non mais je vous le dis
cette population là et présentent à
monaco pour des raisons fiscales certes
et les épouses de ces grands patrons en
quelque sorte passent leur temps à faire
des dîner de charité s'il faut savoir
quand même qu'à monaco a
indiscutablement il y a le glamour il ya
les pailles et là aussi mais c'est aussi
le rayonnement de monaco est
international il est très très puissant
en matière de charité en matière
d'oeuvres de bienfaisance et charlène de
très très souvent en tout cas annulé au
dernier moment bon nombre de rendez vous
auquel elle devait assister ce sont des
faits avérés cela englobe papa français
au bout de onze ans parce que je la
prend vie
la raison berger a raison bertrand et
bien c'est symptomatique
c'est d'être en afrique du sud il le
fait simplement de venir changer en
permanence à exercer leur esthétique
sont physiques et vous de venir se
couper leur choix pour quelqu'un qui
constitutionnellement est obligé de se
taire qu'ils aient déjà prendre la
parole avec charlène va mal elle est
prisonnière d'un système elle n'en peut
plus de cette démarche je crois et
feytiat monaco où elle est obligée de
jouer un rôle obligé de jouer à rhône où
tout va bien grâce qui disait dans l'une
de ses dernières interviews grâce
lorsque l'on demanda à grace kelly
qu'est ce que c'est le protocole
exactement grâce a eu cette formule
absolument technibel rendez vous savez
c'est difficile et facile à la fois le
protocole ça permet de dire que chaque
personne et chaque chose à sa place
c'est un jeu de rôle de celle de la mise
en scène le protocole et n'oubliez pas
que je refuse à bertry sonne t shirt
chose à sa place et n'oubliez pas que je
fus actrice a les mains de c'est ce qui
a permis à graver émis de rayonner à ce
point de s'investir autant lario aimez
le jazz mais moi la vérité mais le mal
était à
travers elle est actrice nos bêtes
étaient déjà connues et mégots charlet
de la pauvrété nageuse tu en connais
beaucoup des nageuses mais elles sont
sous l'eau déjà tu les vois pas mais qui
n'a fait cas bonne et comment tu veux
dire connaître
il ya d'autres cas je vous rappelle que
diana et viticultrice donc il ya
d'autres cas qui auraient pu alors ait
pu si elle souille d'un agrément oui ça
6-0 ce qu'on doit être inquiet on en est
un qui lui ont détruit onze chars nos
jours d'agonie il faut absolument être
inquiet pourquoi il faut être inquiet
pour charlene est ce qu'on peut faire
pour son destin de femme et à la marina
du défi sportif
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour la vous avez
surtout surtout pourquoi ils vont aider
il faut dire qu'au format très inquiet
parce qu'un monarque il faut que monaco
on retrouve une princesse bien sûr c'est
la bbc vraiment pape avec charles est
dehors il est non absolument pas désolé
il faut faire des prières pour que
j'allais n'est pour que charlène et
mieux
je vous assure vraiment avant d'apposer
une bonne question est ce qu est ce qu
on accuserait divorcer est ce que non ce
serait parce qu'elles vont renoncer à si
constitutionnellement c'est mécénat
lourds est divorcé il ya un autre
problème il ya les enfants ah ouais y'a
les enfants les moyens de fonctionner
les enfants sans même regarder à
la main chaude route dans ricky ou la
belle vie il était il a divorcé il avait
des enfants à cyril martin comprend rien
de ce que vous racontez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la raison je te dis on peut divorcer si
on a des enfants ils croient pas
charlene regarde castanet
ses fans et mes racines femme comme une
autre l épouse du prince souverain de
monaco d'autres d'autres praguois ont
déjà divorcé alors elle peut pas dire
qu'elle ait des poings liés diana par
exemple il y en a eu d'autres en
angleterre surtout d'ailleurs en
angleterre surtout il élit n'était pas
régnant à l'époque je n'ai pas vraiment
d'exemple oxatis doit pas en avoir il
faut que je réfléchisse mais deux
souverains en fonte fuyant qui rouvre ce
n'est pas une question de manque d'amour
c'est simplement une question qu'elle va
pas bien dans sa tête en dépression ou
tu sais pas été ceux qui s'aiment plus
et oui bien sûr que coûte outre le mal
être psychologique qu'est ce que ça
cache pas derrière un projet médical un
vrai pour le modique alors nobody non
mongin vous vraiment qu'il est petit
mais
moi je n'ai jamais dit que il n'ya pas
en manque d'amour au sein du coq à l'âne
à ce sujet en moi je dis juste que elle
souffre est une femme qui souffrait
énormément que le pra stands et des je
pense vrai le croise albert la soutient
oui le prince albert la soutient oui il
ya peut-être une autre afrique
énormément oui c'est peut-être une autre
anecdote que l'on peut rêver mais moi
personnellement je n'ai jamais cru à
cette rumeur à monaco souvenez vous on
dit la veille du mariage charlène tente
de fluides alors soyons tous nus ça
c'est pas vrai ça pas du doigt là vous
me confirmer ça n'est pas c'était pas
vrai joggeurs et là j'avais tenté de
fuir j étais alors vous étiez au mariage
ou à monaco j'étais au mariage était à
monaco et j'ai même chez la première
interview officielle de charlene avant
qu'elle prendrait ça qu'il a des prix
mais voilà
depuis
son départ en bus voilà c'est une eau
plus marc une légende de papier glacé ce
n'est pas vrai mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire si on creuse un peu ça veut
dire qu'il y avait déjà des personnes
dans l'entourage direct du coin c'est
soi-même qui était très mal faits
voulait lui met des bâtiments lunaire
vous confirmez ce que je dis alors je
vais vous dire au palais c'est pas
facile au palais ils ont un quotidien
pas facile mais je connais très bien ce
qu'il faisait beaucoup de respect pour
le prince albert et la princesse on
parle d'un coup c'est un homme
remarquable adorable et mon seul truc
c'est qu'il ya un tas de gens autour qui
se le sont beaucoup moins et donc il m'a
aidé dans les roues à charlène nom et
charlene elle a été peut-être pas assez
entouré par stéphanie était très souvent
là heureusement quelques gentils
stéphanie très adorable s'est bien
occupée et charlene se trouvait paumé
dans une situation extraordinaire entre
guillemets avec des gens chef c'était
farinas est arrivé comme un ouragan mais
non
ils se rencontrent en 2005 il se marie
en 2011 la plaie l'éternelle fiancée on
peut pas dire ça elle a quand même eu
une période où l'amour est plus adapté
canberra oui mais c'était très difficile
parce que le fait d'être après officiel
il ya déjà tout un tas de gens autour
plus difficile et qui se sont eux qui
ont fait un peu barrages moi je vous
dire moi je les connais très bien et je
suis très désolé satisfaction c'est on
est tous mais jouer d'ici sont très
amoureux les toutes premières
s'exclame-t-il ça c'est le plus
important oui c'est toi qui sais pas ce
que c'est pas de moi d'ailleurs olala à
s'équilibrer c'est vrai que c'est pas de
moi pire c'est de nana mouskouri non pas
qu'ils disaient j'ai reçu l'amour en
héritage et un matin au pays des cigales
et charlene elle n'a pas reçu que cet
héritage prince ihala audrey le calme
ont reçu d'amour et c'est qu' un grand
amour entre le prince albert et charlene
est que quoi qu'il arrive l'amour
triomphera je te le dit bertrand je te
le dis ce soir ça va s'arranger je sais
que t'es pas bien précieux sont en
électricité statique mais tout ça va
retomber mon chéri état va repartir du
bon pied charlet parce que je la kiffe
moi ça arrive tu lui diras dire tu la
connais c'est du pur plaisir
merci maintenant je me dois chan a
besoin chaque année surtout
pas que les appels je fais une barca je
les invite je rigole avec eux cette
dépression qui sont cousines d'arkham
non je sais pas si tu auras albert et
charlene a bien sûr que les choses sont
en train de bouger tu aurais plutôt à
et mme eliane n'y serait plus un
numéro d'appel non mais chez numéro
d'albert bien sûr la bombe numéro d'ald
albert chemouny
[Applaudissements]